there's a bunch of stuff in the news
about mutations of the virus in the
united kingdom
i also saw in south africa something
maybe that was yesterday
uh you just kind of mentioned about
stability and so on
which aspects of this are mutatable and
which
aspects if mutated become more dangerous
and maybe even zooming out what are your
thoughts and knowledge and ideas about
the way it's mutated all the news that
we've been hearing are you worried about
it
from a biological perspective are you
worried about it from a human
perspective
so i mean you know mutations are sort of
a general way for these viruses to
evolve
right so so it's you know it's uh
essentially this is the way they evolve
this is
the way they were able to jump
from you know one species to another
we also see uh you know some
recent jumps there were some incidents
of this virus jumping from human to dogs
so you know there is some danger in in
in those jobs because you know every
time it jumps it also mutates
right so so it when it jumps to
to the uh to the species and jumps back
right so it acquires some mutations that
are sort of
um driven by the
environment of a new host yeah right and
it's different
from the human environment and so we
don't know whether the mutations that
are required uh
in the new species are neutral with
respect to the
human host or maybe you know maybe
damaging yeah change is always scary but
so are you worried about i mean it seems
like because the spread is
during winter niles seems to be
exceptionally high
uh and especially with a vaccine just
around the corner already being actually
deployed there's some worry that that
there's
this puts evolutionary pressure
selective pressure on the virus
and for it to uh to mute for you to
mutate
is that as yeah well i mean there is
always this thought
you know in in in the scientist my mind
uh
you know what happened what will happen
right so
uh i know they've been uh they've been
discussions about
sort of the arms race between the you
know the ability
of of the uh of the you know humanity to
uh you know to get vaccinated faster
then the virus you know uh essentially
you know becomes uh you know resistant
to to
the vaccine um i
i mean i don't worry
that much uh simply because
you know there is not that much evidence
to that
to aggressive mutation around the
vaccine exactly
you know obviously there are mutations
around the vex
there are vaccines so the reason we get
vaccinated
every year against the season of those
mutations
right um but uh
you know i think it's important to study
it
no doubts right so i think one of the
you know to me and again i might be
biased uh because
you know we we we've been uh trying to
to do that as well
uh so but one of the critical directions
in understanding the virus is to uh to
understand its evolution
in order to uh sort of understand the
mechanisms the key mechanisms that
lead the virus to jump you know the
nordic viruses to jump from
species from species to another that
the mechanisms that lead the virus to
become
resistant to accidents also to
treatments
right and hopefully that knowledge was
uh will enable us to sort of forecast
the evolutionary traces the future
evolutionary traces
of those virus
you